happy new years happy new year to you i
hope you had a uh i hope you had a more
pleasant one uh than i did i had little
ugly experiences in my new years which
i've already told everyone about
involving vomit oh yeah yeah but uh once
or
not me no i don't get the wrong idea no
but uh it was just it was just a night
where it's hard in new york city i think
to have like a pleasant new year's you
know it can be it can be kind of your
own
let's not get into that
[Music]
that is none of your
business because of drinking no someone
else yeah i explained earlier in the
show i someone else vomited don't you
watch the show from your dressing room
i was talking to my wife you didn't even
that was no excuse i did watch the show
and i did see i did see something that i
would like to ask the audience to
participate in speaking of new year's
that you mentioned during the monologue
show that i am paying attention i heard
in the monologue uh that conan said that
he his resolution would be to no longer
milk the audience for applause yes
as a performer i understand that but as
a performer i also know that he doesn't
mean that
so
i would like to request not only to this
studio audience but the future audiences
that come here and to all all of america
basically as they and and satellite
countries as i heard mr richards was
watching yeah
yes that that at any point uh
not not to your knowing when this point
would come not the best english but i'm
an actor i'm not an english teacher so
uh that at some point you would just
rise as i would like to ask you to do
right now everyone in the audience rise
please and give conan a standing ovation
go ahead
[Music]
thank you very much
thank you
thank you
oh my god
and and please those of you that will be
here on future nights if i'm not here to
advise you of this uh just do it at any
time just pay attention to what they
tell you here just do it just do it he
will respond i'll guarantee you you also
if you just do it at home if you're
watching at home on your set do it there
we'd appreciate that too yeah well
that's what i meant thank you yeah that
really came from their heart too
when it's so unexpected like that you
you have
it's it's a very moving thing very nice
very nice well i do have to ask you did
you have a nice new year's eve that's
the i did we basically sat around my
little one went to a friend's house
because it's his birthday every new
year's which kind of sucks if you're a
little kid
because you never have your party with
your friends you have to have it at a
different time but then you do get two
presents so he was off there and then my
son isaac and my wife catherine and
myself we made a little turkey dinner we
sat there with our dogs and we sang the
abc song
what is the abc song well uh my son
isaac said why don't we just start at
the beginning and make a resolution we
should just start all over again right
and i said sure he said well so we
should do the abc song so i would like
another group participation
right now
okay all right andy if you take that
come on over here andy if you take this
area of the house right
here go so colin yeah all right here we
go here we go
now let's uh let's divide let's divide
the house let's divide the house right
here okay so this is not this is number
three you're number two and you're
number one okay number one okay
okay
now
okay now
okay i've i've never tried this uh other
than at the dinner table and my wife
can't sing a note so it was completely
unsuccessful
but i wish you luck we will do the abc
song in a round okay all right now you
begin and here we go and you lead them
this is the abcs now don't be nervous a
b c
d e f g
h i j k l o n o p
a b c d e m g
d
y n z
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
next time come to sing with me
[Applause]
[Music]
i was afraid to ask but how old is your
son that wants the abc song oh he's 12.
oh
i was like i was really afraid it was
going to be he's 34 years old
yeah
he just likes it is my bald spot that
old that big oh my god
no but uh thank you for uh for that song
first of all it's gonna be it's gonna be
a chart topper now well
do you do that
you have such a nice uh
she has such a nice relationship with
audiences do you do that kind of
interactive stuff in the in the shows
you tour around sometimes i do sometimes
certain things certainly i'm going to do
the abc song from now on you just gave
it birth thank you it's now
they all want their cut too by the way
they'll get it
when you i know you you tour colleges
too you do a lot of performances at
colleges you must get
requested all the time your speech from
the princess bride yeah you get that all
the time well they usually sit for about
an hour and a half listen to all the
songs i sing but their only desires for
me to hear the one line is for them to
hear me say the one line from the
princess pride
will you favor us now with it
why not
hello
my name is inigo montoya
you kill my father
prepare to die
that's a fun conversation
it's a little depressing when you're at
a concert you sing your heart out for
two hours and that's all they want to
hear
[Laughter]
and they love it uh well i was backstage
i actually talked to you for quite a
long time yeah we had a good time
usually i go into people's dressing room
before and just you know hi how are you
nice to meet you you and i got wrapped
up in a very long conversation i noticed
that while you were there i noticed you
had this giant bag right what was it it
was uh it was uh i had to do an
interview on cnn earlier and uh there
was someone there who actually was uh
the distributor for manichevits matzah
for all of long island
well
that's heaven to me
i i requested to be the spokesman for
their product and lo and behold she
calls her father the girl who runs the
show and says he's on the way to pick me
up can i wait 15 minutes a guy comes up
he's got a whole box of stuff gives me
chocolate chanukah candy uh gives me
matzah bagel pretzel matzah and
everything and uh and so he gave me that
because uh i like matzah
you have you have like a year's supply
back there well well i've often as i'm
sure this has happened to you sometimes
actually i knew that glenn close was a
friend and she said once that she had
mentioned something about a certain
product i'll say who cares fritos in an
article the next thing she knows a
truckload of fritos comes to her house i
have mentioned everything i've ever
wanted
on on every single interview i've never
gotten a thing right backstage i talk
about man of chavez they're sending me a
crate of matzo
which i'm excited about yeah that's very
nice do you get
you get a lot of do you get jewish
groups often approaching you wanting you
to to be involved is your is your
culture you know a big part of your act
it is it was almost a small it was
actually it was almost diminished by
even a certain degree early on in my
life uh even greater than the natural
diminishment that most jewish men go
through
what conan is referring to that
i didn't refer to it what we do
what they do with these shows they ask
you a few questions so you got any
interesting stories you'd like to tell
so i mentioned this one story and code
says well how do i bring that up i mean
you know i thought i did it very
artfully and nice beautifully and what
the story is it's the fact that i was
circumcised twice
and uh
conan wanted to hear why i just want i
just thought that we could all help you
with this painful memory
actually i have no painful memory about
it i look at it now as an excuse for
anything that you might read about me
for the rest of my life but
what happened was i was born in mercy
hospital on the south side of chicago
which has since been torn down it's a
catholic hospital my mother was a good
jewish woman she goes there i'm born and
the nun comes into the room and says mrs
patink and we'd just like you to know
that your son's circumcision went fine
my mother has a heart attack and says
what are you talking about what are you
talking about he's jewish there's
supposed to be a bris which is the
ceremony that they take
care of you
and uh and what do you mean
nun says condoms but then calm down she
runs out of the room she comes back a
few minutes later with the doctor and
the doctor says to my mother mr tinkin i
just looked there's enough left for the
ceremony
oh man
so i would like to show you now
[Applause]
being late on tv you do that sort of
thing yeah you could do that this late
at night you know people just be
watching going huh that's interesting
yeah
maybe i'll stick with this rather than
the infomercial yeah a little longer
well uh it was a real threat it's the
end of my interview huh
not at all i'm just there's a network
guy saying get him off get him off
no actually uh we're we're out of time
unfortunately but uh i wish you'd i wish
you'd come back sometime because we
didn't get to
one-tenth the stuff we wanted to talk to
and you're you're a lot of fun to have
on the show i'd love to come back
sometime i'd love to thank you all right
let me mention that chicago hope really
a a really good show is uh just move to
mondays at 10 p.m on cbs and people
should check it out
all right mandy patek everybody
thank you very much
he's trying to get more applause all
right close we'll be right back